The fact is, essentially, any type of psychologist could examine this case.
However, the specific question of why no one reacted when a lot of people saw
and heard it would be examined by a social psychologist. Cognitive
psychologists usually look at how people perceive things, remember things, how
they solve problems and things like that. And a developmental psychologist.
We'll look at how thought and behavior changes or remains the same across the
lifespan. So it might be confusing, because a clinical psychologist deals with
diagnosing mental illness. And in this situation may help to determine if the
attacker was mentally stable. But again, this question was focusing on why no
one helped. That could also be the case for a forensic psychologist. A forensic
psychologist might want to examine the person who committed the crime or the
crime itself. Now, the key here is that even though this question was directed
towards a social psychologist. A clinical or even a forensic psychologist could
also examine this case. But I'm going to send you to Greg to talk a little bit
more about forensic psychology.